ladies and gentlemen we are back with
joe manganiello the star
of arch enemy now in
arch enemy you play someone who has so
many questions about
himself including whether he's a
superhero
or not and what do you want
audiences to take away from their
experience with archenemy
i want them to have many many many
questions
all the answers are there but it's
cryptic and you might need to watch the
film a second time to pick up
you know the little nuances of little
subtle hands
or breadcrumbs um you know yes it is a
story it's we meet this man who
is homeless he lives in a tent under a
bridge
he's uh you know a drunken drug addict
uh who's in a lot of pain um he's
uh crazy delusional and he battles on
and on and on
anyone who will listen about how he was
this
like basically a superhero from another
dimension a parallel
universe that found his way to earth and
lost his powers
uh and no one believes him other than
this
one teenage blogger who's looking for
content for his
blogger pages and uh and he starts
recording these stories
about my character max and
uh and they kind of go on this this you
know
adventure together sort of i mean you
know it's basically like a a
you know story of redemption for my
character trying to find his own purpose
so
um the question is is he crazy or
is he actually telling the truth okay
now um we have played this game on the
show
um with award-winning entertainers and
olympic gold medalists
and now we would love to play it with
bubbles your dog
we're going to ask some rapid fire
questions and learn everything we can
about bubbles in
bubbles in a minute
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh thank you joe for playing okay here
we go
ready okay does bubbles
prefer to walk or be carried uh oh
well she loves running running running
running running
but um she loves being carried too so i
don't know it's kind of like 50 50.
understood bubbles if you were starring
in a movie
who would she want to direct it uh greg
jacobs who directed magic mike xxl you
know we did a road movie
and i it was like a buddy picture about
you know and i think that
it's that kind of heart that uh bubbles
and i could do like a road movie
directed by greg
what is bubble's favorite food oh i mean
she loves whenever i eat bacon she loves
bacon
but she also likes jicama she has a nice
healthy jicama snack in the afternoon so
if bubbles gets arrested who is her one
phone call
oh me for sure it's all about it's all
about dada
[Music]
for sure what do you hope is bubbles
last thought before she goes to sleep
each night
i'm sure she's probably dreaming about
her breakfast as soon as she goes to
sleep
is she dreaming of a bacon jicama omelet
yeah as gross as that sounds she would
probably love that
thank you so much joe manganolo arch
enemy is in theaters and on digital
and on demand right now and of course
bubbles thank you um so much and
really joe it's been a real pleasure to
talk to you today thank you so much for
coming on this show
thanks drew it was great talking to you
this was so much fun
and like i said i've been a big fan for
a long time and uh
and you know thank you so much for
having me on thank you
joe mangano